what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and John Humphrey over here today
we're gonna review the Netflix original
Stephen King adaptation Gerald's game
directed by Mike Flanagan before we go
into that we wanted to give you guys a
quick intro on a new app that we're
working with right now called sir dust
that's right guys if you like movies you
like TV you like anything we do here on
this channel then you're gonna love
startups yeah you might have seen some
of your other favorite youtubers already
using this app I'm so happy to be a part
of it hello everyone and what star dust
basically allows you to do is to record
and share your own reactions for up to
30 seconds to pretty much any popular
film television show or trailer that you
can think of so it's perfect for us you
can also set up a watch list keep track
of all your favorites connect with
friends and there's even a way to guard
against spoilers which is handy so you
can find us on start us at the real
rejects you can find mark and Christian
from the schmoes know over there Clark
wolf over there you can find late to the
party Jeremy John's and of course all
you guys as well so if you're interested
in the app hit up our special link down
in the description box downloads start
us and make sure that you follow us
first at the real rejection region
that's the real rejects all one word to
download the app and follow us first so
they know we send you and last but not
least if you connect with us on the app
you'll even have a chance to be featured
in one of our upcoming reviews that's
right for example Blade Runner 2049 is
in next movie we're gonna be reviewing
so if you download the app record your
reactions to the trailer or your
thoughts going into the movie then share
that to social media tech us is the real
rejects tag Stardust official handle
you'll be in the running to have your
reaction featured in our next review and
we might even discuss a few of your
thoughts so hit that link in the
description box download Stardust and
make sure to follow us first at the real
we need to beat Jon flicks dirt we do
and there's no better way to do that
than by reviewing a movie called
Gerald's game Greg I know you love this
movie if you guys already follow us on
the Stardust app you'll see we posted it
quick our quick 30 second thoughts on
the movie already
this review it's good it's pretty good
at well it's well done it's really well
done I think there's what to say I
enjoyed it there's like a big
distinction
I wasn't like sitting back going like
I'm really enjoying the hell out of this
movie in fact it was kind of frustrating
for me and it really tests your patience
it's all deliberate it's all intentional
you're supposed to sort of feel that way
so I get it I just wasn't prepared for
the mood the movie it is kind of a grim
movie everything in it is very dark all
of the subject matter yeah present there
are some flashback things like
everything about this movie pretty much
is dark uncomfortable a little bit
depraved so like I do get it's like a
hundred minute movie and like 85 minutes
of it it's just depression it's just so
dour a you know it it is you gotta
respect it so much because it's like the
situation this person's and if you guys
haven't seen the trailer for this movie
I thought the trailer look pretty bad
actually I didn't love it's way better
than the trailer that's for damn sure
yeah the trailer it's nice when a
trailer doesn't give away too many of
the surprises the movie has and and the
things that the trailer does reveal just
look confusing out of yeah yeah in this
movie Gerald and Jesse Jesse played by
Carla cugino Gerald played by Bruce
Greenwood they are having marital
problems I want to spice up their sexual
so they take a weekend getaway - yeah
included you know lake house and he has
some kinky thoughts and desires and then
he cuffs her to the bed but she's not
really getting into it because not kind
of foreplay he wants to do about that
King clip and while they're having like
a pretty good marital argument like I'm
pretty realistic are you at the end they
were having yeah
and I respected that because the trailer
makes it look like hell they just gonna
fight and then this thing happens but
it's a good argument yeah everything
unfolds pretty naturally especially in
the lead up to the set up you know yeah
so what happens is he has a heart attack
while she's huffed and she's just
stranded on this bed this trailer made
it look like it's gonna be one of those
like maybe fun movies of how she gonna
get out of the bed like a buried or
shallows where it's one location and
it's kind of this her own cat-and-mouse
game how she's gonna get out of there
and there's like a dog in the trailer
he's made it look weird and dumb the
movies really a much more of a
psychological tale of a woman having to
confront her past traumas in order to
get out of this situation yeah kind of
building the the drive and the the
wherewithal to actually fight and to get
out of this terrible situation instead
of doing what she's always done which is
not a lot yeah where she runs yeah and
he can't run when you're trapped she
goes into didn't I in terms of all those
aspects I really appreciate it I could
see this movie being a very empowering
film for women in general and for
especially women who have suffered from
like sexual abuse in their past it does
a pretty good job on telling a
metaphorical tale and beyond
metaphorical it is pretty literal
actually yeah and it's really well done
there's some interesting visuals a neat
use of flashbacks and I thought it was a
fascinating journey of this woman who
was having to confront the timeline of
her Strama in order to figure out how to
survive and get out of this situation
and then there's some interesting stuff
in there too where you know like she's
trapped on this bed for a long time and
very early on in the film you see it in
the trailer she starts to hallucinate
and start seeing Gerald who's died early
in the film yeah it's a setup of the
movie it's not a spoiler to set up he's
dead yeah you see Gerald and he's like
the the interpretation there was a
perception she has of him cause she's
like hallucinating he's still alive and
talking to her that was all interesting
and it's like one of those things where
anytime I have a complaint I already
know what the counter-argument
I don't have a counter-argument towards
those complaints because I get it I see
why people like this movie it's just not
a very enjoyable movie for me it's
pretty dark and most of the subject
matter is pretty uncomfortable I mean
this movie yeah those from stranded
during this failed sex scenario to like
revisiting some pretty visceral traumas
that we don't get to I'm not gonna like
spoil everything but we don't discuss
this a lot in my mainstream no no no and
so yeah most evening Kings not afraid to
do it yeah very Stephen King movie it
does I thought they did a nice job of
bridging a sort of middle ground where
it does feel like it's based in a book
or it feels kind of like a play but it
does feel like a movie distinctly as
well and yeah I cannot blame you for not
being into it but that's part of what I
enjoyed about it is what movies do
bother to take those dark and
uncomfortable things and actually you
know Mia characters jump into and
dissect them and overcome them that's
cuz the movies like it starts here and
then it just keeps going to press to
press the whole time yeah there's very
little it's not a roller coaster of ups
and downs it's very funny there's like
no hope ever it's just this woman's
suffering yeah it's will she or won't
she and also what is going on in her
head to her credit carla Gugino this
might be the best performance
she's ever seen yeah I've seen a pretty
good amount of her movies you know Spy
Kids in Sin City I was wildly impressed
with her performance yeah I was too cuz
she essentially place two characters
here - yeah yeah and she gets to play
two very different demeanors based on
that basically - but one character yeah
she plays like two versions of this same
exact character and she's amazing at
both and it kept making me wonder like
how did she film these scenes cuz she's
not bouncing off of anyone when she's
talking to this other version of herself
which is like the stronger version of
the weak woman you know I would be very
curious to hear about that because in
theory she's just talking to herself
yeah so in a way that might have been
natural she does a terrific job and so
does Bruce Greenwood I mean seeing them
together I like a movie like this in the
sense that it's contained and small it's
mostly just two characters for the
majority of the movie and to see those
two actors who just aren't
yeah you know
your household a list there is something
every weekend actors I was like these
guys are terrific together I didn't
realize how cut Bruce Greenwood is I
don't know guys for this fit scene in
shape but he's half naked for most of
this film I'm gonna be in my underwear
this it's kind of an agonizing
experience in a lot of ways but yeah yet
I'm like everything about it that I
didn't enjoy I constantly respect it
because I got it well and then I'm also
like well then what else that you can't
really make this like a whole full
journey already yeah yeah this isn't
gonna be fun I'm gonna be
tongue-in-cheek every you know so what I
did really respect about it was it took
a completely different route than what
the trailers and sort of marketed to be
as it's much more deliberate it's much
slower it's much more of a psychological
journey it's more of a character it's
kind of like a 127 hours but she's stuck
in bed yeah yeah yeah or like a weird
more more indie drama version of SAW
yeah an intentional sob but there are
elements where I was very much reminded
of saw for some reason coming down to
the technical stuff I think Mike
Flanagan again has proven that he's
capable of doing a lot of different
facets of this genre and the way it's
shot it's a lot of very long takes very
deliberate camera motions like it's a
very restrained movie but that's
something I definitely expect about
there also some amazing color palettes
like at some really cool distinctive
color and design choices and stuff like
that there's this whole event that takes
place during a solar eclipse solar
eclipse that like that that the film
constantly references back to and
there's cool visual imagery taking place
within that there's also some elements
we're like is this gonna be kind of
supernatural I can't test but you gotta
watch the movie to find out what the
hell is really going on and I thought
that was handled pretty well in terms of
writing
I can't spoil it for you guys because
it'll give it away but I thought the
finale was a little bit rushed and
there's like it's a whole lot of
exposition and
there's like a fourth act on this movie
yeah it's like the third act feels like
a fourth that yeah weird most of the
film as yet is is one place so yeah
there's a kind of coda at the end that's
something else and that's the only not
necessarily even that sequence but that
particular plotline is something I'm
still chewing on a little bit still
figuring out how I feel about in context
of the overall story I just thought it
didn't flow well with the rest of the
the EB like 80 minutes it is this sort
of immediate and very deliberate you
know pained thing and then yeah it
branches off from that no way that's
like whoa yeah overall I'd say it's a
pretty damn good movie carla Gugino
rocks this film she is she is the main
reason I think you should watch this
film especially if you're in the mood
for like a powerful empowering
performance yeah and it's pretty well
written I mean all the performances are
good and all the technical essentials
just be prepared it's not a fun exciting
movie it's it's rather dreary it's a
verbal The Sitter it's not in any way
like mother but I guess I appreciated
this on that level of like well I guess
the point was to make me feel
uncomfortable and confine it yeah good
job but I can't blame anybody for not
liking to just watch people hire movie
in those most people seem to really like
it most people like it sounds like a 92%
of Rotten Tomatoes and I'm more like a
three and a half stars kind of guy with
this movie I was closer to before the
thing is like I'm not champing at the
bit to like watch it again immediately
but I do think it'll probably stick with
me did it make me feel good in it and
hey it's a good time to be Stephen King
you know yeah hopefully fingers crossed
from 1922 to comes out next that would
that would be terrible if that had the
great trailer and ended up suck well
guys did you see it cuz that's not the
movie we watch have you seen misery or
Engadget have
seen Gerald's game if you haven't it's
on Netflix so watch it whenever you want
if you saw Gerald's game please put your
comments down in the comment box below
would love to hear what you got to say
about the movie totes anyway guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell follow dat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram I'm at
the Greg Alva and make sure to check out
our patreon become a patron eject today
yeah and last but not least don't please
follow us on Star does the app and
follow us first yeah a lot of youtubers
that we follow on youtubers I know you
guys follow are using this app as well
and we're happy to be part of the
community over there because it really
is a great app and it's so cool to see
that there's a lot of us who are really
getting into this habits it really is a
fantastic app join a 30 second thought
to be your movie review we're taking to
him to put it together just they're just
making tiny bring your one honest yeah
if you just want the quick and dirty
come on out well we'll do is we'll make
them only spoilers only spoil all square
is 30 seconds of straight later on 20 49
Ryan Gosling dies hairs here support
know and they're all replicants yeah we
haven't seen Blade Runner donor